étranger
[Applaudissements]
ers
garçons votre mère est morte
elle est morte parce que vous l'avez renvoyée elle
était faible malade dans son esprit
vous saurez ce que je fais oui le pouvoir
est une question de force
si vous montrez de la faiblesse
vous donnerez une ouverture à nos ennemis
[Applaudissements]
étranger
comme sa mère, laissez-lui
ce qui s'est passé ce jour-là,
j'ai regardé la mort en face et pour la
première fois, j'ai vu mon vrai moi me parler
de ce chasseur,
ils disent qu'il utilise une connexion avec
des animaux pour suivre sa proie
une fois que vous êtes sur sa liste, il
y a  seulement un moyen de nous six
et un seul d'entre vous il y a six d'entre vous
maintenant
exactement comme notre père juste
un autre homme à la recherche d'un trophée
nous sommes des meurtriers
n'est-ce pas ce qu'il nous a appris
nous ne pouvons plus me faire ça
Mr taglin
Mr techlin
où est Mr tagley oh tu te tiens en
lui
ton [ __ ]  fou oh tu viens de comprendre
que maintenant
il y a un animal en chacun de nous
tu ne veux pas savoir pourquoi ils m'appellent
le rhinocéros